I'm humbled to be here thank you for
having me throughout the presentation
I'll refer to some resources I'll make
them available to Tina and you can reach
out to me and I'm happy to provide them
I want to start with the stories of two
Hardware founders the first Hardware
founder has degrees in engineering and
MBA from top schools
he left the largest hardware company in
the world in 2015 to co-found a start-up
whose goal was to make amazing products
that truly made the world a better place
he gotten a Y Combinator and assembled a
list of investors including some of the
most prominent individuals in Silicon
Valley the company launched from the
largest Hardware campaigns in
Kickstarter history he delivered a
complex product that was made in the USA
to over 46 countries 15 days after his
30th birthday when the first show and
the first commercial product shipped he
had accomplished one of the ultimate
career goals in his life taking a
product from the concept to mass
production and into the hands of
customers his company has shipped over
15,000 units it is currently working on
some exciting future products the second
Hardware founder also co-founded a
company in 2015 and from day one has
been plagued by doubts and fears of
failure he spent months prototyping and
fundraising for his company trying to
move the product forward with a weekly
crisis that looked like it would end the
company for good he was drew from
everything except work he launched a
product that was over budget eight
months delayed and took 15 grueling
months of all-nighters in 80-hour
workweeks
15 days after his 30th birthday the day
the first commercial product shipped was
one of the loneliest and emptiest days
of his life this wasn't his bottom he
burned himself out so badly he spent a
year gasping for air emptiness
relentlessly expanding
depressed and for lack of a better word
broken he needed to take a leave of
absence from his own company just to
begin recovering his company has shipped
over 15,000 units and is currently
working on an exciting future product
case you can get it
these are
same founders the first story the
external story in the second story the
internal story are both true the gap
external versus internal of fairy tale
from reality is the gap where I burnt
myself out in front of everyone that
worked with and interacted with this is
my story when I started Nebbia I didn't
know the second story could exist I
never imagined my internal story would
include me falling to pieces I never
thought that something like that could
happen to me with this presentation I
hope to eliminate the second story from
the experience of all the founders in
this room I hope to share with you how I
got here and the concrete things I wish
I would have known and done and some
things that I did do too before I before
I had this enormous fall to avoid
burning out I don't believe every
founder of stories like this but for my
discussions with past and present
founders I do believe there is a gap
between the external and internal
stories and within the gap lies the
deepest personal struggles of a start-up
founder before I dive in I want to
preface what I'm about to say this is my
story the things that happened to me
along the way
it is shaped by a lot of factors some I
controlled and some I didn't I'm white
male whose parents prioritized education
above all else I've been privileged in
ways I will never know and never be able
to truly appreciate in as such they're
shaped my story in ways that I'll never
truly know you may be wondering why
should I care about this burnout stuff
just because it happened to other
founders doesn't mean it's going to
happen to me well let's take a look at
what causes burnout there are range of
causes of burnout at work but the
research shows these are the key ones
overcoming challenges with changing
atmospheres unrealistic deadlines
unpredictable schedules physical demands
added responsive at a dance ability
without clear guidance and difficult
interpersonal demands with colleagues or
customers and these are the characters
characteristics of an early-stage
startup aside from physical demands they
are eyed
integral the environment of an
early-stage startup is one of the
right.this places for Bernal as is
getting an advanced degree like a PhD or
an MD or going to work at a top company
in an incredibly demanding role I know
everyone in this room is interested in
this world and it's an exciting world
this is why it is important for you to
pay attention to yourself and to be
aware and conscious of burnout we also
need to define burnout it was not
something I truly knew the definition of
before I started scouring the internet
to figure out what was wrong with me by
stepping through the stages of burn out
together my hope is that you will
recognize them in the future
the fact that you're here means you are
credibly driven but that also means
you're more likely to fall into burnout
burnout syndrome first appeared in the
medical literature in the 70s but
descriptions of the symptoms can be
found throughout history including the
Old Testament in the early 80s twelve
stages of burnout were published I'll be
using a bridged version of these to walk
us through my experience you don't
necessarily go through all the stages
and they're not always linear but
burnout usually starts with a compulsion
to prove himself and ends with
depression and eventually burnout
syndrome this is what happened to me the
first stages of burnout were slow and
insidious looking back I chalked them up
to stress I kept getting worse but it
wasn't that one day I was happy in the
next day I was depressed I slowly got
worse day by day sometimes hour by hour
sometimes I would feel joy or excitement
just for a second and then it's I
stopped feeling altogether
a small change from the day before but a
monumental change from two years before
I fell and fell and I ended up at the
doorstep of the final stage of burnout
total mental and physical collapse
well follows are the things I wish I
would have known as a 27 year old before
I started in MEA the things I wish I was
doing the things I wish I was paying
attention to some things that I did well
is some things that I think saved me
Stage one is the compulsion approval
itself as I mentioned the fact that you
are here means you're incredibly driven
but that also makes you more likely to
start down the path of burnout and it
starts with the compulsion to prove
yourself a desire to demonstrate your
worth obsessively proving it not just to
others but to yourself I remember
walking into math 51 freshman year I was
terrified because my high school only
taught a B calc you know although I
tested into math 51 I didn't know if I
was prepared when I walked into the
first lecture there's someone I knew
from one of my Emmy classes so I decided
to sit beside him he quickly said I
don't know if I should be in this class
I smiled huge grin and I nodded I was
like yeah me too he continued I took
linear algebra a junior year of high
school and I crushed it but I might need
a refresher I was terrified I sat there
and smile frozen inside all my fears
were coming true I didn't deserve to be
here I was in over my head
Stanford made a mistake how am I going
to be an Emmy major when everyone is
years ahead of me I don't remember that
lecture at all but I remember how
terrified I was the entire time turns
out I did deserve to be there I got
through meThe 51 in 52 and 53 kind of I
graduated with an MA degree came back
for master's I was a Mayfield fellow I
took some long nights and a ton of hard
work but Stanford didn't make a mistake
and Stanford didn't make a mistake with
anyone else you deserve to be here
you deserve to sit across from a famous
VC or in the boardroom of a company when
you get there doubt will creep in and
you'll wonder what the hell am I doing
here I'm in over my head you're not you
deserve to be here
you deserve the opportunities that come
your way seize them this is an amazing
place and although you deserve to be
here you can never forget how fortunate
you are for the opportunities you have
when you forget that you could become a
person no one wants to work with you
become the worst version of yourself
when there's a fancy article written
about you when there's buzz all around
what you
don't drink your own kool-aid you're
lucky to be here I worked hard to get to
Stanford long nights studying
extracurricular all that jazz both my
parents are immigrants my mom came to
the US for grad school with the plan to
return to Venezuela if you don't know
the history of Venezuela he used to be a
pretty frie iving d'leh developed nation
it's now a post-apocalyptic why a novel
where it's pretty hard to find toilet
paper let alone medicine I don't do
anything to convince my parents to leave
their family and friends and stay in the
u.s. wasn't my skill as I convinced my
parents to prioritize education above
anything else can give you a hundred
more examples just like this and I'm
sure there's a thousand I don't even
know so never forget how incredibly
fortunate you are to be here and
whenever possible you should pay that
good fortune forward with kindness and
support of people who may not be so
fortunate so what can you do about the
doubt the doubt goes by another name
it's called imposter syndrome and it
happens to a lot of people a lot of
people in Silicon Valley but in business
and also academia the first thing you
can do to combat it is just recognize
doubts you observe them you're okay with
them you don't need to prove them wrong
you don't need to work 100 hours a week
you just noticed they come up and you
observe what triggers them second a
little bit of positive self-talk goes
really far we're often hardest on
ourselves when you catch that voice in
your head beating yourself up just stop
it
imagine you were giving your best friend
advice I guarantee you wouldn't be so
mean to him and lastly put one foot in
front of the other start doing that
thing that terrifies you that you doubt
you can do you will notice two things
one you can do it in - everyone else is
kind of full of - they're just
learning as they go and to ensure you
don't let you know this stuff get to
your head you don't drink your own
kool-aid make sure your friends are the
ones who are around before you were
famous co-founder or there is TechCrunch
articles written about you and make sure
they call you on your BS stage -
involves working harder with the
inability to stop
many things contribute to burn out but
the bigot the biggest volume item is
what you do at work and it's also the
key place you see the effects of Bernal
there will always be more work to do it
start at a startup then you have time to
do if you don't prioritize and
personally understand what work you
should be doing you will work harder and
longer until you can no longer do
anything this is burnout in a nutshell I
want to focus on how you prioritize work
and figure out what work you should be
doing I wore several hats at Nebbia I
started off doing our D and then
engineering and then operations as we
grew I started to manage the R&D team
and manage the engineering teams however
know no matter how far I fell how burnt
out I got I never hired an Operations
team and that was a huge mistake at
Apple I was a global supply manager the
role involves solving hard problems on
how to make a million of a certain part
a day it also involved negotiating and
pushing vendors because I did it at
Apple I did it at Nebbia what I didn't
realize is I really hated a large part
of that role I loved solving problems
but I really hated negotiating and
pushing vendors I could have hired
someone to do it and manage them however
I had so many other things on my plates
so many of the things I needed help with
I didn't I just did it myself it was a
full-time job we have two dozen vendors
and hundreds of parts the frustrations
constantly pushing pleading arguing with
vendors quickly pulled me down the path
of burnout on top of that I ended up
doing it pretty badly
looking back my mistake wasn't doing a
full-time role on the side of my
management responsibilities although I
really don't recommend him doing that if
you can avoid it my mistake was that the
role was life draining instead of life
giving there are some things even really
hard things that energize you and they
give you life that is where you want to
spend your time as much as possible so
what can you do first let's talk about
prioritization you can do a million
things at a startup and there will
always be more things to do especially
if things are going well the
opportunities will flood in if you try
to do them all
you will fail you need to focus you need
to decide what are nice to haves and
what are need to have focus on the need
to have the bells and whistles of a
product meaning a c-level celebrity
hiring your second barista
these are nice to have if you have the
bandwidth do them but first do the need
to have nice versus need to have also
help you align everyone some people may
disagree on what is needed and what is
nice that's fine that's actually good
you should debate it you don't leave
until you're in agreement by getting
agreement amongst founders and amongst
your team you're all aligned and what to
prioritize in the direction to go in
once you finish all the need to halves
feel free to do all the nice-to-haves
second I want to talk about your role
how do you find the correct one to be
clear your role will change over time in
a startup it will evolve based on the
needs of the company in your skills this
framework is one way to look at where
you should be spending time steena
mentioned I went to business school it's
mandatory to have a two by two in any
presentation you do if you go to
business school I actually think this
one's useful though so bear with me the
x-axis is passion for your work in the
y-axis is ability so ability pretty
straightforward
are you good at it can you do it well
passion goes back to that life giving
versus life taking when you're
passionate about it it inspires you
every day you get up in the morning
excited the day kind of flies by that's
that's where you want to be spending
time let's start in the bottom left
things you don't like to do in your bat
I think it's obvious but you shouldn't
do these things you should find a
co-founder who you trust and you get
along with and they should do these
things if you don't have a co-founder
and this is an important role
you can fire you should hire an
executive to do it the key here is
you're not going to want to manage this
closely you're not going to want to kind
of dive into it because you don't like
it and you're not good at it
going to the bottom right quadrant there
are things that you like to do but
you're a bad at this is where you should
invest in yourself in a few moments I'm
going to talk about learning and how you
learn better this is
you should apply that process read books
talk to people work on it take the time
to make yourself better and in turn
you'll make your company better this is
my ballpark estimate but you should
spend 75 percent of your time in that
top top right quarter
quadrant this is the stuff that you're
good at and you like to do because
you're at a startup
you'll actually have to continually hand
off things in this top right quadrant
it's fine it's part of the game as you
grow you won't be able to do everything
the key is you should be back filling
with things that you like to do and
you're good at lastly I want to talk
about the most dangerous Quadrant for
burnout good at but dislike doing this
is where I burnt out in this quadrant
you want to hire someone to do this role
you're perfectly suited to do that you
know how to do it so you can manage them
and you don't like it so you're not
going to even a static and want to take
it back over that said it's really hard
things are moving fast there's about a
thousand things you need to do and
because you're good at it you're like
you know what I'll just take care of it
don't do that invest in other people for
this quadrant find someone who loves
this role train them work with them make
them better than you are or you were
ever at this role in stage 3 you start
neglecting your basic personal needs
when you are stressed and starting to
slide down the slippery slope of burnout
is incredibly easy to neglect your most
fundamental needs you can't it's a
recipe to accelerate down that slope in
early 2017 I knew something was wrong
with me but I didn't know what to do I
didn't know why but I realized I wasn't
myself
usually I was productive fun-loving
social I found that by the afternoon I
would sit in front of my computer frozen
anxious I couldn't process email simple
decisions felt like life or death I was
paralyzed by the most basic choices in
complex important ones like reliability
issues cost issues engineering
challenges felt impossible on top of
that I really didn't want to see other
human beings which makes you a pretty
bad boss we've by week I found that it
would hit me earlier and earlier in the
day first things I'd he was overwhelming
at 2:00 and then at 1:00
and then at noon you get the drift I
didn't know how he could get better but
I knew how to try something so when a
friend drew a triangle on the board he
asked me how I was doing with sleep diet
and exercise I hadn't thought about
those three things in probably a year
maybe longer but I was willing to try
anything
so I started prioritizing sleep food and
working out when I was doing each one
perfectly I could function again till
1:00 p.m. two days of bad sleep three
days of eating only burritos I was back
to getting crushed by 10:00 a.m. when I
caught this I'd focus again I'd work on
my sleep
make sure that I was eating healthy and
I'd get back to 1:00 p.m. it didn't
reverse my symptoms but it did allow me
to function a little better every day
and it bought me time to figure out how
to fix myself don't worry I'm not here
to reteach you fifth grade health class
but I will say that the fundamentals are
really important in this case the
burnout fundamentals are your physical
health a three-legged stool diet sleep
exercise nailing this alone won't stop
you from burning out but it will delay
it can give you enough time to
course-correct early in the first stages
instead of the doorstep of collapse the
thing about these three pillars of
physical health is you can neglect them
for a couple weeks you don't realize
there's ramifications but eventually
it'll catch up with you you skip a
workout to get more work done you eat
burritos three days in a row before you
know it your Energy's lower and it's
harder to concentrate to compensate you
skip the next workout you sleep an hour
or less and eat another few burritos
you get the picture I'm not saying you
shouldn't pull an all-nighter or skip a
workout when there's an emergency these
things happen but when they do you need
to lean really hard than other two legs
of the stool and get back to normal as
soon as possible if you don't you will
slowly deteriorate first physically and
then mentally right now I bet you can go
to the French house till 2:00 a.m. get
back turn in that problem set at 8 go to
class at 11 and still feel fine
just remember that you have the
opportunity to nap all afternoon and
recuperate even though that's not
necessarily what you think you're doing
so right now when you have the time if
your gear out how much sleep
you can take sleeping dreams I'll teach
you all about it and give you three
units figure out what food works for you
what diet is healthy and figure out what
exercise motivates and energizes you you
can see exercise come up a bunch more
times in this presentation it's not just
about physical health look this may seem
pretty boring right now but this stuff
becomes more important as you get older
I sat in this seat ten years ago and I
called on very similar
recommendations I felt invincible but it
will matter more and more so all I'm
saying is pay attention to it
do yourself that favour at Stage four
you start to revise your values when you
get into the heart of burnout you start
to sacrifice things and make decisions
you would have never made you structure
revise what was important to you things
outside work start to disappear you
prioritize work above all else at the
expense of everything else our product
had been delayed again we were all ready
to start shipping in November and one
cosmetic part was messed up we were
going to be delayed months for one
non-functional part so over the 2016
Christmas vacation my family who's been
incredibly supportive decided to do a
holiday in Sonoma so I could be close to
the office even though I hadn't had a
vacation in a year I worked every day of
break I was possibly the worst son
brother and boyfriend in the history of
a Christmas vacation all I thought about
was chef inna product getting it out the
door I was sure that fig that shipping
it would fix everything spoiler
it didn't a few weeks after Christmas
was my 30th birthday I didn't want to do
anything I needed to work I needed to
ship my product my girlfriend's sister
Don taking me on a long weekend to
celebrate and actually get away we went
up north for three days I insisted I
couldn't I needed to work she insisted
more I remember driving to Mendocino
terrified that we weren't gonna ship the
product asking myself what the hell was
I doing taking a weekend off we got to
the hotel and she went to check in she
my cell and she told me I had to come in
to sign some papers I walked into the
lobby and I stopped everyone in the
lobby was looking at me it seemed kind
of odd that I noticed a close friend
from San Francisco what a coincidence
that he would be here too but I guess it
was a long weekend then I noticed
someone else I knew one of my best
friends from high school then I realized
that I knew everyone standing around the
lobby were my best friends from
preschool all the way to business school
the people who I loved more than anyone
in el else in the world my girlfriend
and sister had been planning this party
for six months I was obviously clueless
my friends flew in from all over the US
to surprise me I was speechless it was
one of the best weekend's of my life I
turned off my phone for more than a few
hours probably for the first time in a
year over the we over that weekend that
realized I hadn't seen some of those
people in a couple years two friends
whose wedding I officiated I hadn't seen
since the wedding it wasn't a few months
before let's just put it like that
throughout life I valued my friends more
than anything and I'd completely
abandoned that value I didn't recognize
the person who stood there shocked by
surprise in front of all his friends I
hated the person I had become burnout
had revised my values they were reduced
to one work all I valued was shipping a
shower what had happened to me well some
habits like how much sleep you need may
change your value shouldn't not without
serious consideration before you become
a founder you need to know your values
and why you are starting a company the
solution to not letting this happen to
you is to define explicitly your values
so you can visit them often my
recommendation is to do this for
yourself the way the best companies do
you define your values your mission and
your vision there are many ways to
define your values you can look up a
list of 100 online and pick five to
seven that resonate with you the way I
used was whenever I saw a quote that
resonated with me I put it in a list
eventually that list got to be able
hundred quotes and I went through them
and I characterized them by values I
ended up with Severn primary values and
v secondary values keep in mind that
these aren't static concepts you need to
revisit them often eventually they may
change but they should change with
deliberate consideration after defining
your personal mission values and vision
you need to consider if you are compact
if they are compatible with founding a
company so looking at your values must
answer the question why am I starting
why am i doing the startup if the answer
is to make money don't I I cannot stress
this enough
your highest net present value as a
worker is that Goldman Sachs McKinsey
Apple many other companies will pay you
a ton of money to work there you'll do
awesome stuff it's it's not a bad play
site I recommend it in the long run your
MPV will be much higher working for
these guys at the startup of course
there's outliers but they're just that
outliers everyone here understands
statistics you know how that works there
are good reasons to start a company but
you need to understand your reasons why
do this thing you want to do in the
hardest possible way because that's what
you're doing if you want to build
hardware there are companies who do that
you don't have to do it from scratch if
you want to save the world many places
are doing that a hundred different ways
go join those companies when we do a
start-up if you are convinced it is the
only way to achieve your dream and then
make sure its mission its visions and
event and its values aligned with yours
by Stage five denial problems and
displacement of conflicts
you've diverged completely from that
first stage the compulsion to prove
yourself you're panicky you're
short-tempered you see everyone else as
falling short of what they should be
doing and you bring aggression and
cynicism to every contact you have
nothing is your fault the world is to
blame as I mentioned I'd taken very
little vacation at Nebbia and I was
actually even worse before I left Apple
having used one vacation or sick day in
my entire tenure the lack of unplugging
was a key factor in my descent to Bern
that Christmas vacation where I worked
every day and was a terrible son brother
and boyfriend I ended up returning just
as frustrated empty and destroyed as
ever it was the worst of all worlds
people described a start-up as a
marathon not a sprint
and I completely agree when you run a
marathon you take water at Mile three
even though you're not thirsty
you don't take water at Mile three so
you can run mile four super fast
you take it so you can survive and
thrive at Mile 23 when your legs are
shaky and your knee hurts and your brain
is screaming stop at a startup you take
a three-day weekend in month five not so
you can perform in one six you take it
so at month eighteen or month thirty six
when your funding is running short
your product is delayed then you just
lost a key employee you can sit down
clear-headed form an action plan and go
execute by this point without vacations
or time to reflect I'd become a
miserable I've become a pretty miserable
co-worker a friend and significant other
although I barely held it together with
my team I lashed out at my co-founders
whenever I thought they did something
wrong instead of trying to understand a
problem and troubleshoot I would get
angry and launch blame my friends had to
listen to endless complaints about
vendors and generic challenges and
everything else that was eating me up in
March of 2017 two months after we
started shipping nevia's two months
after everything was supposed to be
fixed I finally took a vacation took 10
days went away
spent a little time alone I read slept
exercised but above all I reflected I
spent time with myself the part of me
that was unhappy the part of me that was
broken it was a turning point I realized
I had to do something I finally started
to brainstorm what still took six months
from there for me to take a leave of
absence how do you avoid getting to
where I did you get to know yourself
knowing yourself means understanding the
behaviors and emotions that are going
through you right now
unlike values which you set and rarely
change these are ever-changing and
understanding them is key to responding
to them instead of just reacting
this is probably the most important
thing you can do to stop yourself from
sliding down the slippery slope of
burnout my recommendation and what I
wish I did was find out where and how to
best listen to your deepest thoughts the
thoughts that get hidden by the urgency
of work social life bills and everything
else that always takes president
precedent I want to be clear these are
not the voices in your head that beat
you up with doubts or obsess on
conversations in the past or problems of
the future this is past that this is the
part of you that truly understands how
you are feeling and what you want if you
don't carve out time to reflect and
connect with this side of you you will
start to make rudderless decisions and
no matter how hard you work you will not
end up where you are trying to go people
do different things to listen to
themselves
Ron meditate pray hike list goes on I
can't tell you what to do or what will
work for you you need to find that for
yourself but find out what combination
of activities on a weekly or daily basis
allow you to listen to yourself I can't
stress this enough having these places
activities and times is a real
game-changer furthermore there are
several specific situations we're
getting to know yourself pays huge
dividends and a start up and in avoiding
burnout one of these situations is how
you do a stress start ups or stressful
you're going to you're trying to create
something from nothing you have to deal
with every type of problem under the Sun
problems you never expected to deal with
when you started a company there will be
stress knowing how you deal with stress
and a healthy way is gonna be key in my
early stages of burnout all of my
symptoms seemed like stress but I didn't
have an effective way to consistently
deal with it I'd get to a breaking point
and lash out where I'd go home and allow
bad mood to permeate everything it was
not exactly a fun person to be around
this is not an exhaustive exhaustive
list of activities that may help you
deal with stress but there are some
ideas here you need to figure out what
works for you as you develop your own
process to deal with stress keep in mind
you want to deal with it in a healthy
way even originally healthy
stress solutions can turn pretty
unhealthy so going for a run every time
you're anxious is awesome it's a great
way to deal with stress running a
marathon every time you have a bad day
will probably end up killing you going
out with drinks with friends great way
to unwind having 12 drinks with friends
every time you have a bad day also will
probably kill you find out what works
for you give yourself the slack both in
terms of your schedule and your life to
go do them I'm gonna quickly go through
some of the other things you should know
or know about yourself before you do a
start-up you should know how you learn
you should know how you take feedback
you should know have you have hard
conversations you know sure you should
know how you deal with unexpected
problems I know what you're gonna say
I got into Stanford I learned pretty
damn well and I'm sure that's true
especially when it comes to standardized
tests and 10-week courses startups are
anything but standard in the only
startups I know that are 10 weeks long
failed part of founding a start-up is
learning new skills because you'll not
have all the skills you need on day one
do you know how you learn outside of
school do you read books search google
talk to people learn by doing most
likely it's a combination of these
things in a specific order
do yourself a favor know how you learn
new skills so when you have to you can
just go apply it similarly how do you
take feedback from people because
there's a lot of feedback in a start-up
feedback from co-founders feedback from
investors employees customers some of
its good some of its bad can tell you
that I have had many customers walk out
of a shower and tell me that they do
showered in the worst thing that they'd
ever experienced that's crappy feedback
and it hurts and if I would have taken
that and gone home and had just been
like well no one likes this I should
stop doing it we wouldn't have 15,000
units in the field also when someone
comes out is like oh that's perfect you
don't need to do anything else you
probably also need to be like huh is
this one person's idea is this
everyone's just figure out how you take
feedback figure out how you're going to
implement that feedback conversely how
do you
give feedback mainly have difficult
conversations you need to learn how to
have these conversations if you don't
you don't learn that skill small not big
problems turn into startup stopping
problems they balloon they make life a
lot more difficult and eventually
they'll enter burnout they lead to
burnout
lastly startups are just a series of
unexpected issues on day one you will
never predict what will happen on day 15
let alone year two how do you deal with
problems that come up and unexpected do
you have a process my stage six
withdrawal emptiness and collapse
combined several of the final academic
stages of burnout this is where life
really starts to unravel where all of
what we've talked about catches up to
you in a way that you can't begin to
deal with alone these stages are where
people turn to unhealthy and dangerous
responses like drinking and drugs to
numb the pain and emptiness where if
things go on stopped you collapse both
physically and mentally where you end up
in the darkest of places this section
will not follow the normal cadence of
the other sections the truth is these
stages are messy and while I have a lot
of tactical advice for the first stages
of burnout
I have no frameworks that work for these
next ones at this stage you're not
functioning or logical you're lost I was
broken this section involves investments
you made years earlier it involves the
people in your life you can't build
these relationships once you get to this
stage they need to have already been
there you need to be cultivating these
your entire life some of the best DTLS
talk about the importance of people your
company co-founders hires etc I could
not agree more
the people you work with at a start-up
are among the most important decisions
you will make listen to those ETLs Bain
Allen I want to talk about the people
who aren't on your corporate website the
people who made a difference for me the
difference between walking away from
Nebbia from SF from life as I knew it
the people who have peeled me off the
floor when I was sick to my stomach
tired angry broken
those people are rarely on your cap
table or your board they never have a
photo on the bow me page of your company
they're your real friends and mentors
the ones you were born with the ones you
grew up with the ones who are sitting
beside you right now and the ones who
you'll meet along the journey who have
helped you without any ask in return
they don't just email you when you hit
three million dollars on Kickstarter or
you appear in Forbes 30 under 30 they
email you and they haven't heard from
you in a while they pick up the phone
when you call at 10 a.m. on a workday
because you've been outside crying in a
park outside your office they help you
get out of bed when you wake up nauseous
for the 18th day in a row and you don't
know how you're gonna eat enough to
survive let alone go to work they are
the unsung heroes of every founders
success story the first set of these
people are mentors I both screwed this
up royally and nailed it several times
people offered to help and I was too
embarrassed to take it often where I was
weakest I thought because of my degrees
and experience I should be able to do
this alone I was wrong I learned things
the hard way I made mistakes I could
have avoided because I was too proud to
take help please don't make this mistake
mentors are people who've been there
they don't have to and probably
shouldn't be famous but they need to
care and understand what you are going
through they are a fount of wisdom but
also hard truths they encourage you and
they reality check you most importantly
they don't ask for anything in return
except maybe to pay this kindness
forward I've been fortunate to have half
a dozen people who have done this for me
and they blur into my friends one
particular mentor is a former Mayfield
fellow someone who every time I walk out
of a meeting with him I feel inspired
and ready to execute he's a rare balance
of exceptional intellect a profound
emotional intelligence I could spend the
rest of the talk sharing just a fraction
of what he's taught me but I won't I
will discuss the most important meeting
I ever had with him which is why I'm
giving this presentation today is when I
finally got the nerve to tell him I was
burnt out and I needed a break and how
embarrassed I was that I failed and his
response
without the least bit of hesitation or
anger because he was also investor well
as I'm not surprised this happen many
people go through this you didn't fail
he then shared a story with me of
someone
everyone in this auditorium would
recognize who also had to take some time
off he told me I should take the time I
need that he thought that I'd come back
and be stronger but I if I didn't that
was ok too
that night for the first time in a year
the weight on my chest got lighter
instead of heavier three weeks later I
took my leave of absence if there is one
place where I hit a homerun partly due
to luck and partly due to my value of
friendship in dealing and preparing for
burnout it was a network of people that
surrounded me I can say without a doubt
I wouldn't be standing here today still
struggling but making it through without
the friends from throughout life some
who sat beside me in this very lecture
some of which I'd known since I was 2
when the stress of trying to ship a
physical product that was over budget
and not working forced me to leave the
office at 10 a.m. and go for a walk so I
wouldn't break down in front of my team
I call it a stanford friend when I was
miss missing the Stanford football game
because I had an employee breaking down
threatening to quit I used his bedroom
to take the call
and then we got a burrito and a beer and
he listened to me then when I couldn't
get up in the morning because I was so
nauseous about having to deal with
dozens of vendors who wanted to know
when we were going to start building
units for the millions of dollars of
parts that already made it was my
significant other who helped me make it
through one day at a time when I thought
I couldn't take the weight of
expectations the team that depended on
me the customers who were demanding
their delayed product the investors who
had invested millions it was my sister
with the compassion of someone who loves
you as much as they loved themselves who
listened to me and helped me make it
through
andrina dan andrew andrew lindsay Sarah
mom dad Richard Josh Scott did all of
the people on this slide behind me
they're the reason I came back from the
brink from the darkest place I've ever
been and I wish I could tell you I was
all fixed that I was back to 100% I'm
not but I am working they edit there are
costs to doing a start-up I mentioned
the opportunity cost of salary but more
importantly there's an opportunity cost
in life things outside of work get
crowded out and if you're not careful
some go to zero when you burn out they
all go to zero my friends some time off
and some tough choices help me pull back
from the ledge back to a place where I
can function contribute and get stronger
but opportunities and more importantly
relationships are lost along the way
opportunities that I missed ignored or
blew up and most sadly people who had to
share too much of the burden of a
start-up oh the burnout these lessons
aren't easy for me to share I wish
beyond anything I could go back and
teach my 27 year old self these lessons
I hope that when you start to slide down
the slippery slope of burnout you can
recognize it and use it to pull yourself
off out or if you're fortunate enough to
never be there you can recognize it in a
friend and you can pull them out in
stage 7 recovery from burnout depends on
how far you fall in a long vacation with
some structural life changes could be
enough if you catch it early or a leave
of absence with some pretty monumental
changes if you catch it late if you
don't catch it at all it can end up it
can end you up in a hospital or worse my
road back started with small things like
the health triangle I showed you then I
started to let friends and mentors in
and I started to see a therapist these
things helped but it didn't reverse my
slide I eventually took a leave of
absence and stepped away completely I
didn't know if I was going to come back
during my first month I didn't think
I've returned to SF period blood alone
Nebbia I spent my leave of absence
visiting friends I hadn't seen in a long
time and soul-searching
although it sounds like a vacation it
was brutally hard for me I spent some
nights doubled over with anxiety but
then I spent some nights truly relaxed
without a million thoughts racing
through my head at all times I got
excited by something I saw or ate or
discussion I had and then it happened
again
I visited a new place and saw old
friends in sparks of excitement that I
hadn't felt in years returned I spent
time with amazing people in amazing
places and I Bungie Giada I bungee
jumped off a bridge for good measure I
realized I wanted to come back I had
things I wanted to prove to myself but
more than that I wanted to come back to
SF and Nebbia to contribute and continue
my journey but before I returned I did
all the tactical things I mentioned
above and some others I found a new
therapist Suze I got got back to SF I
started doing yoga as well as running
sometimes during the day
that's when having a shower company
comes in really handy I track my
exercise my sleep in my diet I review my
values quarterly and make sure I'm
spending times on time on things outside
of work I also took ten days to do a
silent meditation retreat one of the
ways I'm trying to quiet the many
thoughts in my head and deal with stress
all of these things have been
instrumental in coming back for the
first time a few weeks ago I was walking
and I broke out into an ear-to-ear grin
teeth showing cheek muscle hurting grin
I cannot remember the last time that
happened but it it was years ago
although I'm not a hundred percent in
getting there day by day sometimes hours
by hour I'm getting to be my old self
well actually a new shelf with my old
excitement and a little more wisdom I
hope that sharing my experience will
help someone avoid the pitfalls that I
have had or perhaps you will notice them
in a friend if I can ever be of help
please don't hesitate to reach out thank
you